se você foi imobilizado por um período
longo de tempo de vida cirurgia gravidez
doença ou viagem você corria o risco
de desenvolver trombose venosa profunda
ou tvp
a decisão em que os quadros de sangue
se formou numa via profundo do corpo
normalmente a perna
diferente das rasteirinhas que contam
com o coração para forçar o sangue
através de
às vezes transportam o sangue com a
ajuda de contrações musculares
enquanto você se move caminha
veias também são válvulas que evitam
que o sangue flua de volta e se acumule
nos braços e pernas
quando você está imobilizado por um
longo período sua circulação venosa
se torna mais lenta
como resultado fatores coagulantes no
sangue podem fazer com que o sangue
movimento lento ser como ele formando um
coágulo sanguíneo com o trombo
esta condição é chamada de trombose
venal profunda ou tv tem
sintomas comuns de tv pensão
injaz só da perna ou de uma veia da
perna
dor ou sensibilidade na área
aquecimento crescente da pele
e pele avermelhada ou descolorida
os de tvp um coágulo pode se deslocar
da veia profunda e entrar na corrente
sanguínea
o coágulo viaja na veia profunda da
perna
dez das veias do abdômen
até o coração
e finalmente se aloja na artéria
pulmonar ou suas ramificações
bloqueando o fluxo de sangue aos
pulmões
esta condição
chamada embolia pulmonar é muito séria
e pode danificar permanentemente uma
porção do pulmão
se eu colaboro foi grande ou se houver
muitos colaborasse
a embolia pulmonar também pode levar à
morte
se você apresentar sintomas de embolia
pulmonar por favor avise seu médico ou
enfermeira imediatamente
sintomas podem incluir isso
perda de inspiração
dor repentina e aguda no peito
uma sensação de atuar dimento ou
tortura
batimentos cardíacos acelerados ou
irregulares ou torce que produz sangue
para ajudar a prevenir a trombose venosa
profunda e embolia pulmonar seu médico
pode pedir o seguinte
caminhe periodicamente para evitar que o
sangue se acumula em suas pernas
os e meias de compressão
e tome medicamento anticoagulante